est notre invité du jour c'est vous et
rien à dmitry de chine bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes spécialiste de
l'ukraine historienne messrs de
conférences à l'inalco l'institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientales une première question il ya
ces avancées qu'on attende on se
félicite les ukrainiens depuis quelques
jours il ya évidemment ces propos hier
soir de volodymyr zelensky et puis cet
après midi le porte parole de l'armée
kényane qui fait état d'avancées sur le
front sud un front un peu plus complexe
qu est ce qu il faut comprendre derrière
tout cela aujourd'hui les ukrainiens ont
préparé leur offensive depuis plusieurs
semaines en faisant des choses avec
beaucoup d'intelligence de ces
constructions en préparant le terrain et
que maintenant après avoir fait
plusieurs leur en fait plusieurs
attaques on savait pas s'ils allaient
attaquer dans le sud dans l'est de
dollars que du côté des russes non plus
visiblement c'est cela qui aurait
impressionné c'est ça qui a qui a
fonctionné sérieux plusieurs ce que
j'appelle les leurs en fait il ya
vraiment des dd des choses qui ont été
lancés qui ont fait croire que l'attak
aura lieu du côté du sud obligeant les
russes à dégarnir les certains côtés
pour concentrer les troupes dans le sud
est finalement le france yves commence
plutôt du côté de rares qui tout en tout
temps sur poursuivants du côté de chez
sony ou dans le dôme bath et donc c'est
cette stratégie et ce côté très pensée
de la tap qui a été précédée je vous le
rappelle par la destruction des
entrepôts des munitions des réseaux
d'approvisionnement de l'armée russe qui
a coupé la les troupes russes 2 lors de
leur arrière et tout cela permet à le
cren d'aller vite et a désorganisé en
fait tout simplement les troupes russes
qui bat en retraite de manière
désorganisée comme on dit il il serait
tir victorieusement alors que les
ukrainiens avance lâchement donc c'est
alors que les russes n'ont pas tout à
fait le même propos et ils disent qu'il
se retire pour se repositionner et se
réorganiser autrement quand on voit ces
images on a peut-être l'avoir à nouveau
à l'écran de soldats ukrainien arrivant
dans les rangs des villes des villages
et parfois des localités hautement
stratégique is you notamment ce drapeau
ukrainien
qui flotte de nouveau au dessus de au
dessus de ces localités on serait tenté
de penser que les cartes sont en train
d'être redistribuées qu'on a un tournant
du conflit est ce qu'il faut pas quand
même se méfier pas être tentés de
vouloir aller retrouver je pense que les
ukrainiens d'abord ça fait six jours
qu'ils avancent le ministre la défense a
dit qu'il y aura une arrêt en quelque
sorte pour donc asseoir les positions
donc ici c'est pas tout d'avancé il faut
aussi donc revenir assez saisissant
qu'il est notre proposition est pour
nous n'est pas allé perdre en cas de
contre attaques russes les ukrainiens
ont je dirais une triumph lucide c'est à
dire qu'ils sont conscients que il ya un
prix terrible qui a été payé que ce prix
va continuer à être payés donc il faut
patiemment prendre mètre par mètre
kilomètre par kilomètre village par
village mais cette je pense clairement
il y à un renversement de situation
maintenant il s'agit pour les ukrainiens
de tenir et d'affirmer cette victoire
est avancée est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
le ministre de la défense a déclaré que
nous sommes parvenus du côté de rares
cas sur la frontière administrative
entre l'ukraine et la russie ce qui est
déjà si constitue une réelle et a peint
plus que plus que symbolique des fonds
comprend l'objectif de le crunch comme
la d occupation de l'ensemble du
territoire alors les russes le kremlin
le port par le kremlin a réagi au
lendemain évidemment de c2c annoncé
annonce que les objectifs restent
maintenus on est peut-être dans la
façade mais en tout cas les russes
explique qu'ils sont en train de
bombarder intensément les localités qui
viennent d'être reprise par par les
ukrainiens étaient tout à l'heure avec
notre correspondant à kiev qui
effectivement nous confirmer une frappe
sur sûr car qu'il est ce qu'il ya un
risque très fort de représailles
aujourd'hui il y aura forcément des
représailles mais nous craignons dépassé
le stade de la peur c'est à dire qu'il
ya eu tellement d'exactions il ya
tellement de choses tellement dadre cité
de destruction accélération de comus que
le seul objectif aujourd'hui des
ukrainiens c'est la victoire on n'est
pas dans les dents les pourparlers n'a
pas besoin de paix à tout prix on a
besoin de victoires et les ukrainiens
vont se battre et la réponse des russes
étaient d'une grande lâcheté ils ont
bombardé les centres donc les les
centrales électriques thermiques qui
approvisionner en électricité les
régions de rares qui veut bien vrai
black out dans la pareille à celle de la
queen dans la partie est sachant qu'on
arrivait on va vers la d re l'hiver donc
ce qui veut dire que si ce genre
d'opération se poursuit et il ya un
risque de pénurie à un chauffage en
électricité en eau puisque cela les pom
pom qui qui font fonctionner les saints
donc les les centres d'approvisionnement
d'approvisionnement en eau mais
le président us qui a une très belle
formule hier en répétant en scandant
presque donc on oser vous voulez qu'on
soit sans eau et bien on sera avec le
husa avec l'électricité la seule chose
qu'on aura passé vous sur notre
territoire avant ukrainien s'était faite
de manière extrêmement extrêmement jolie
et scandé donc donc je pense que les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui annonce avoir
récupéré restaurer 80% de deux
d'approvisionnement en électricité dans
le qualité qui ont été bombardés et
effectivement la réponse des russes et
de la destruction massive et donc c'est
quand même cocasse de voir que les la
russie qui prétendait libéré les la
population ukrainien du nazisme
aujourd'hui s'en prend à cette même
population en bombardant les centres
vitaux de c2c ville pacifique on voit
certaines fissures qui apparaissent
aussi en terrain russe de grandes
figures qui jusqu'ici ont défendu les
intérêts et la parole aussi du kremlin
on voit certaines interrogations quand
même émergé aussi au sein de la
population notamment dans l'est dans les
médias les médias russes est ce que tout
cela est un signe justement qu'on est
peut-être un tournant et que le rapport
de force peut complètement sang versé
vous y croyez vous
je sais pas si on vous parle le rapport
de force on peut parler je pense de la
différence entre un peuple qui se bat
pour son pki défense sa terre qui défend
son indépendance et une armée
d'occupation ce qui compte ce n'est pas
la taille c'est la motivation bien sûr
il ya aussi les armements occidentaux
qui ont été livré à l'ukraine et qui est
de l'ukraine a bombardé vous avez vu ces
hommages appuyés rendu aux australiens
notamment aux américains donc ses armes
qui ont permis donc la destruction des
entrepôts et des et des tirs mais c'est
l'endurance du peuple ukrainien qui est
sa principale force ça vous êtes en
train de dire je pense oui je pense
qu'on se bat pour pour sa terre et
panique rennes c'est résister pour
exister les ukrainiens sont conscients
que si l'ukraine arrête de se battre et
l'ukraine arrête d'exister et donc c'est
ça qui c'est la motivation qui joue les
remontées que vous avez aujourd'hui du
terrain des ukrainiens c'est quoi
exactement il ya évidemment plusieurs
niveaux dans l'appréhension
psychologique de de cette guerre sans
études même si c'est pas appeler comme
ça par parler par les russes l'effroi
d'abord et puis on s'adapte et puis on a
décidé d'aller au bout où il ya une
concentration et ne dira pas une colère
froide mais mais là la conscience claire
qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout qu'il ne
faut rien lâcher si si tu es fatigué
bien tu te reposes un petit peu et tu
reprends et on a oublié et l'ukraine a
vraiment fait preuve de cette
organisation horizontale c'est à dire
chacun fait ce qu'il peut là où il peut
avec les moyens dont ils disposent donc
donc de chacun contribue à l'arrière
front au milieu donc ceux qui peuvent
prendre les armes et l'ont fait les deux
il ya tout un pays qui est derrière son
armée est aujourd'hui rend hommage à
cette armée et ont sans oublier les
terribles prix qui est payé parce que
les pages facebook aujourd'hui c'est
donc on voit défiler les la joie de voir
tel village libéré tel km avancées etc
et en même temps on a les photos des
jeunes hommes deux jeunes femmes qui
sont tombés au combat donc double
gagnants sont extrêmement lucide il n'y
a pas de triomphalisme
la gears est si vous voulez on est on
est on est ravis on ne boude pas notre
plaisir mais on est conscient que tout
cela va prendre encore du temps et qu'on
est prêt à aller jusqu'au bout on reste
sobre effectivement merci beaucoup et
rina dmitrik chine d'avoir été à nos
côtés et aujourd'hui visité notre